but we begin with breaking news out of
occupied East Jerusalem where Israeli
forces have stormed the Al-Aqsa mosque
and fired rubber coated bullets and Sun
grenades during Ramadan prayers video
shows women and children crying for help
as Israeli forces beat Palestinian
worshipers with batons a few
Palestinians have been reported injured
Israeli forces are accusing worshipers
of barricading themselves after
exceeding the agreed timings hundreds
have been forcibly removed from the
sites let's bring in Al jazeera's
Natasha go name who joins us on the
phone from occupies Jerusalem Natasha
what more do we know happened
well I do want to point out that this is
not a surprise yesterday on social media
I saw the bombastic rhetoric circulating
on social media with calls for
Palestinians to come to Al-Aqsa mosque
in anticipation of uh the Passover
holiday on Wednesday morning in which
Jews will be expected from seven o'clock
in the morning until 11 30 to visit the
compound as part of non-muslim visiting
hours so this these type of clashes
again were expected based on what I was
seeing on social media as you mentioned
the police are saying that dozens of
people barricaded themselves inside
el-aqsa mosque late Tuesday night into
Wednesday morning they say the police
that the the people had a stockpile of
stone sticks and fireworks the police
say that they attempted to coax the
people to come outside of the mosque
there was an agreement with the compound
authorities that no one would be
spending the night police say when they
could not coax the people to come out
peacefully that is when they entered the
mosque and began firing stun guns and
forcibly removing people as you said
people have been there have been some
injuries and there have been arrests
yeah the Jordanian foreign Ministry is
condemning this attack the jordanians
are the custodians of this holy site
Hamas as well is also condemning this
saying it is an unprecedented crime and
people quote should inflict upon the
occupation the price of this crime the
images we've seen are quite shocking
some of them at least are still pictures
that we've seen of worshipers in in
handcuffs lying on the ground
and again Sun grenades being fired as
People Prayed Natasha remind us of the
significance of this site of Al-Aqsa and
why it's such a flash point of tensions
between Palestinians and Israelis
well we should also remind our viewers
that these types of images and these
types of clashes are not new it's an
ongoing cycle of violence especially at
a time like this so this year as last
year Ramadan Passover and Easter are all
overlapping so that's increased the
desire for uh the three modest people
who follow the three monotheistic
religions to enter the compound in this
case we're talking about Jews
particularly and Muslims and what do the
clashes how do the clashes really begin
it's an issue of access and restrictions
Palestinians have already been
restricted to access them off during
Ramadan if you're 55 years old or
younger and you're a man you're going to
need a permit to enter uh and now of
course people were are being told that
during this period of Ramadan they would
not be permitted to spend the night
inside the mosque on Wednesday morning
between beginning at seven o'clock local
and until 11 30 Jews will be expected in
larger numbers than usual to come into
the compound in honor of uh Passover
holiday they will not be allowed to pray
that is a red line they never uh enter
the mosque but they do uh roam around
the compound and this is obviously a
always a very tense uh situation uh the
Palestinians feel very strongly about it
because the type of Jews that enter four
visiting hours for non-muslims tend to
be very conservative nationalists okay
Natasha thank you very much for that
update let's show you the scene now in
Nobles in the occupied West Bank where
as you can see people have taken to this
to the streets to protest there after
the storming of the Al-Aqsa mosque
earlier by Israeli forces who fired
rubber coated bullets and Sun grenades
during Ramadan prayers people taken to
the streets to protest this latest
action by Israeli forces we'll keep a
close eye on the situation there and
bring you the latest as and when we have
more information
in the meantime let's move on to the
indictment